speaking of not being able to trust the
media here's another reason why this is
a story from I want to say here's a
story from NBC News by a reporter named
Matt Levites
here's the headline
far right figures appear to be testing
Twitter's boundaries for anti-lgbtq
speech Elon Musk the new owner of
Twitter has built himself as a champion
of free speech and vowed to prevent
Twitter from becoming a free for free
for all hellscape
this is a story that he already tweeted
it out to when he said it in his tweet
he said that uh you know there are a
bunch of conservatives and far-right
figures who are uh
tweeting slurs against LGBT people now
so that's the way this is Being Framed
so where it's hate speech we're we're uh
you know engaging in slurs and all that
kind of thing here's the article in the
few days since Elon Musk closed his deal
to buy Twitter far-right users have
started to celebrate what they hope will
be the ability to freely use homophobic
and transphobic rhetoric and make
threats on the social media platform
on Saturday former UFC fighter Jake
Shields who has over 340 000 Twitter
followers appear to be testing the
boundaries of the company's moderation
apparatus by posting a photo of a drag
queen smiling at a young drag performer
with the caption this is a groomer
Shields added I was suspended for this
exact tweet a month ago so we'll see if
Twitter is now free the word grooming
has long been associated with
mischaracterizing LGBT people
particularly gay men and transgender
women as child sex abusers on Friday
conservative podcaster Matt Walsh who
describes himself as a Theocratic
fascist lauded musk's acquisition of the
company and encouraged his over one
million followers to start misgendering
trans people
we've made huge strides against
transgender Walsh tweeted in just a year
we've recovered many years of ground of
uh of ground conservatives have
previously surrendered The Liberation of
Twitter couldn't have come at a more
opportune time now we can ramp up our
efforts even more
laws are changing and public opinion is
changing Walsh who held an anti-trans
protest in Nashville attended by
thousands last month continued we have
done all this intentionally was all part
of the plan that we laid out and
executed okay so I I make it into the
article of course and now and I could go
and get and he gets the lives of tick
tock and a couple others
at no point
does he actually provide an example of a
quote far-right person
um using a slur
and at no point do is it does he give
any example of um anyone making threats
or encouraging threats
there are no examples of that that's how
the article is set up there are no
actual examples of it
um the word groomer is not a slurp it is
an accurate description of what these
people are doing
it's not a compliment either but it's
when we're accurately describing your
evil Behavior there's no there's no
complimentary way to describe it
um I did say that I'm looking on for to
going on a misgendering spree on Twitter
I've been saying that all along
but of course by misgendering I mean
correct gendering
so that's not a slur either
no actual examples even though that was
I was trying but here's the point
in in the original article now this is
apparently has been changed
but the original article says
um after the part where they're quoting
me
uh the reporter claims that he reached
out to me and I didn't respond to a
request for comment
okay
well and that has that language has been
removed
but it was there originally you know I
love spending the holidays with my
family and one of the ways that I like
to do that is with delicious meat from
good ranchers as a special gift to my
listeners this holiday season good
ranchers is giving away two Black Angus
New York strip steaks free with your
order uh these are two 12-ounce
Steakhouse quality cuts a 70 value that
you get for free black angus tastes
better and it's more tender than any
other beef black angus meat is marble in
such a way that the fat is distributed
thinly and evenly this marbling gives it
a consistent flavor that you don't get
with other meats plus the Black Angus
from good ranchers is hand cut and
trimmed by expert butchers so you know
every piece is going to be Exquisite go
to goodranchors.com Walsh and use code
wall should check out for this special
offer that's goodrancers.com Walsh for
two Black Angus New York strip steaks
free with your order but you don't want
to miss out on this so go there now to
goodranchors.com good ranchers American
Meat delivered
well this reporter he reached out to me
yesterday morning and told me that he's
working on an article he's right he's
writing an article about you know the
anti-eligibility rhetoric and he he just
love he'd love to get my take on it
because I'm going to be included in the
article and he'd love to get my
perspective as well in fact he begins
his message hope you're well
exclamation point but he'd love to get
my uh he'd love to get my opinion on it
he says
in fact I could pull it up I'll tell you
exactly what he
I'll tell you exactly what he said okay
so he he wrote me yesterday I said this
is yesterday 8 21 a.m he says hi Matt
hope you're well I'm writing an article
for NBC news regarding the uptick and
what many would call charged rhetoric
over lgbtq issues what many would call
that's what he is calling it but he said
this it's what many people are saying
I'm going to be quoting a tweet of yours
from the other day and therefore want to
reach out for comment let me know if
you'd like to expand on your thoughts on
this topic looking forward to hearing
from you
so it's yesterday at 8 21 am
and I got this message and I've been
around the block a little bit with these
people I know how it works so he says
he's writing article I got the message
at uh I don't know I saw it 10 minutes
later
and so I went and checked I went to
nbcnews.com and what do you know the
article's already been posted and it was
already posted long before he sent the
request for coming they posted it at
around five o'clock in the afternoon the
previous day
and then he waits for for the afternoon
and evening to pass and then the
following day reaches out to me and says
that he's writing the article right now
and wants to get my comment and not only
that but in the original version of the
article again it said that they reached
out to me and I didn't respond but they
didn't reach out to me and at the time
when they when they published it they
had not reached out to me
they were just anticipating that I
wouldn't respond and so they they
claimed it as if it had happened
um and I saw this and I and I messaged
him back and said hi Matt I see that
you've already published your article
timestamp seems to indicated it was
published the day before you reached out
for comment is that correct
he says yes the original version of the
story was published yesterday we'd
appreciate your comment on this topic if
you have anything to add
and I did have something to add and I
messaged her back I said I think you
understand that it's a tactic to publish
a story wait until the initial push of
traffic has died down and then ask for
comment from the people you've smeared
in the article I don't care if you guys
are partisan vultures masquerading as
journalists I just preferred if you
didn't insult my intelligence by
pretending that you want to hear my
perspective for an article that you
published yesterday
haven't had a response after that after
I after that
this is the tactic of course they
published the article with all the
smears and everything making claims uh
you made threats you you uh you you
engaged in slurs and all the rest of it
then you get the initial push of traffic
get the traffic overnight you wait till
the traffic has died down and no one's
reading the article anymore now it's NBC
news so not that many people are going
to read it to begin with but
um like 90 of the people who will read
it will read it in the first few hours
that's just the way that it works uh
that's just that's the nature of the
beast when you're in the content
creation space on the internet and they
know that so the following day it's like
no one's reading it anymore and then
we'll we'll update it with your comments
these people are as I said to him in my
response these people are partisan
vultures and then and then they have the
nerve
uh as I said it annoys me
the fact that their soulless lying hacks
I get that part of it okay I accept that
um but yeah it's just insulting my
intelligence I don't I don't like
you know don't insult my intelligence
you think I'm stupid enough to buy this
you use a tactic like this and I'm not
going to notice
it's like it's like I say to my kids
sometimes when I you know I tell them to
go clean their room and then they go up
there and they just shove everything
right under the bed and like I can and I
can see it poking out from under the bed
and I come up and and I say the same
thing like don't insult my intelligence
kids this is this is you think I've you
know I was a kid myself
you you want you want to get away with
not cleaning your room you're just going
to put everything under the bed like I'm
not gonna notice that
like I haven't like I didn't do that
myself as a kid come on
they're gonna try to fool me at least
put a little bit more effort into it
say the same thing to these people in
the media
um but then on top of it they have the
nerve to be offended
when people don't believe them
when they tell us the official version
of a story like with Nancy Pelosi and we
don't immediately accept it they pull
stunts like this
and then are upset when we don't
immediately accept everything they say
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]